When I was a child growing up,
I expected that we would have robots by
this point c three Po and,
and we still don't,
in fact the smartest thing that we have
is the Roomba vacuum cleaner.
And so that means it's something went
terribly wrong with ai and,
and it,
it forces us to ask what went wrong
because essentially we've been throwing
the smartest people on the planet at
that problem since the 60s and it's been
a failed problem.
Um,
the answer I think clearly is that we
have to listen to what mother nature is
doing.
So since the 60s people have thought,
okay,
look,
there's all this wet,
biological gushy stuff.
Let's put that aside and just figuring
out what would intelligence take,
how can we just do this from scratch?
And that hasn't gotten us anywhere.
The game now is shifting to saying,
all right,
how is mother nature accomplishing it?
The reason ai got stuck is because
programmers have been saying,
look,
how can we solve this part of the
problem and then solve this little part
of the problem and this part of the
problem.
So if you,
if you have a robot and you want it to
pick up wooden blocks and stack them,
programmers have traditionally tried,
okay,
let's solve the find the block problem
and then let's,
once we've done that,
fine solve the pickup,
the block problem,
and then the stack,
the block problem and so on.
And this sort of division of labor seems
like a pretty good idea,
but it's never really gotten us
anywhere.
The difference with what Mother Nature
does is she doesn't come up with
solutions to problems and then tick the
box.
The brain is a,
an end product of a chronic process of
reinvention that,
that Mother Nature always does.
So there's no single solution to
anything.
Instead,
the brain is this collection of
subpopulations that all solve problems
and overlapping ways.
There's no single solution.
So for example,
um,
the detection of motion by the visual
system,
there's not just one way that the brain
does that.
There are multiple ways that were
invented at different points in
evolutionary history and they all,
they all weigh in on the same problem
using different mechanisms.
Same with memory.
We don't have a single memory system.
There are lots of ways that memories get
written in the brain.
If we want to solve the AI problem,
we have to do at the same way that
Mother Nature did,
which is build a machine that runs on
conflict,
that runs on reinventing solutions and
having overlapping,
um,
solutions of the problem space.
And that,
I think is our best hope for unlogged
jamming the field of artificial
intelligence.